d'ici 2023 les épluchures de pommes de
terre ou de carottes n'auront plus leur
place dans les poubelles grises des
restaurateurs une mesure issue de la loi
relative à la lutte contre le gaspillage
pour anticiper cette nouvelle
réglementation 4 tourangeaux ont décidé
de créer leurs tricycles riz à vélo il
collecte jusqu'à 200 kg de bio déchets
par jour une ressource inépuisable qui
le transforme ensuite en engrais de
qualité
coup de projecteur ce soir sur les verts
de tours une toute jeune association qui
fait du bien à la planète
samuel colin bonjour c'est pour la
collecte
deux fois par semaine florent vient
chercher son bac vers une quinzaine de
kilos de déchets organiques mis de côté
par ce restaurant à l'exception de la
viande et du poisson tout y passe
coquille d'oeuf le marc de café tout les
peluches pour la cuisine ça ne change
pas grand chose
on a un petit saut poubelles ont épluché
tous nos légumes
donc jusque là en fait et dans les
livres de mettre les peler papier qui
nous faire les choses comme ça
selon le poids ramasser restaurants et
magasins partenaires reverse une somme
modique les verts de tours sont quatre
aujourd'hui dans l'association
leur objectif collecter dix tonnes à
vélo de matières organiques par mois des
déchets qui pèse pour plus de la moitié
des poubelles des professionnels et
jusqu'à un tiers de celle des
particuliers
ils veulent les valoriser et aussi cette
logique de se dire va finalement il ya
deux problèmes qui sont les sols qui
perdent en fertilisant fertilité et des
poubelles qui s'amoncellent qu'on est
obligé de brûler ou d'en fuir alors
qu'au final en collectant les biodéchets
resortant la poubelle on arrive en faire
une ressource et la finalité la voilà un
compost xxl et une table royale pour les
résidents des lieux
enfin sur le tour est en train de manger
tous les deux faire gagner qu'on a mis
leur salaire semaines
à terme ces vers de terre doivent être
vendus pour les lombricomposteurs des
particuliers 50 euros le kilo associés à
la fabrication du compost
le modèle pourrait être viable et créer
des emplois
l'objectif c'est d'arriver à un modèle
qui permettent de faire vivre deux
personnes et demi
par vélo et remorques bon c'est pas on
ne sait pas gagné d'avancé
on sait que ça va être compliqué et il
va falloir être patient les verts
devraient voir leurs populations tripler
d'ici l'année prochaine
le temps peut être de trouver d'autres
lieux où installer ses compost